Ça nous a permis de comprendre que nous devions parler à l'être humain
et non au soldat.
Nous devions cesser de communiquer
du gouvernement à l'armée, de l'armée à l'armée,
et commencer à parler de valeurs universelles et d'humanité.
C'est à ce moment-là que les sapins de Noël sont apparus.
Sur cette photo,
vous voyez l'organisation du projet des sapins de Noël
et l'homme ici, avec les trois étoiles,
s'appelle Capitaine Juan Manuel Valdez.
Capitaine Valdez est le premier officiel haut placé
qui a mis à disposition des hélicoptères et le soutien nécessaire
pour installer ces sapins de Noël.
Il nous a dit quelque chose que je n'oublierai jamais.
Il nous a dit : « Je veux le faire car être généreux me rend plus fort,
rendent mes hommes plus forts. »
Je suis très ému en pensant à lui
car il a été tué peu après au combat et il nous manque beaucoup.
Mais je souhaitais vous le présenter car il était très, très important.
Il a nous donné tout le soutien nécessaire pour poser les premiers arbres de Noël.
Par la suite, les guérilleros qui ont quitté la guérilla
durant l'opération des sapins de Noël nous ont dit :
« C'est une très bonne idée, les sapins de Noël sont vraiment supers,
mais vous savez quoi ? Nous ne marchons plus vraiment.
Nous empruntons les fleuves.»
Les fleuves sont les autoroutes de la jungle,
et la plupart des recrutements s'effectuaient aux bordures de ceux-ci.
Voilà deux choses que nous avons apprises.
Nous nous sommes donc rendus dans ces villages,
nous avons demandé aux gens,
sachant que certains étaient en contact avec les guérillas.
Nous leurs avons demandé : « Pouvez-vous passer un message aux guérilleros ? »
Nous avons récolté plus de 6 000 messages.
Certains étaient des petits mots disant juste : « Sortez ! »
Certains étaient des jouets. Certains étaient des bonbons.
Certaines personnes ont ôté leurs bijoux, leurs croix et symboles religieux,
les ont mis dans des boules flottantes que nous avons envoyées sur le fleuve
afin qu'elles puissent être collectées à la nuit tombée.
Nous en avons envoyé des milliers sur la rivière
et nous ramassions les restantes.
Mais la plupart était ramassées.
Ça a généré en moyenne une démobilisation toutes les six heures.
C'était fantastique, tout reposait sur l'idée de rentrer chez soi à Noël !
Ensuite est venu le processus de paix.
Que le processus de paix a commencé,
il a transformé l'état d'esprit des guérillas.
Tout a changé car ils ont pensé :
« S'il y a un processus de paix,
tout ça va certainement prendre fin.
Je vais m'en aller à un moment donné. »
Leurs peurs ont complètement changé.
Ils ne craignaient plus de se faire tuer.
Il craignait d'être exclu par la société.
« Quand je quitterai la jungle, serais-je un paria ? »
Alors, après Noël, voici ce que nous avons fait :
nous avons demandé à 27 mères de guérilleros
de nous donner des photos de leurs enfants
sur lesquelles on ne pouvait pas reconnaître les mères pour les protéger,
et nous leur avons demandé de donner leur message d'amour de maman :
« Tu es mon enfant avant d'être un guérillero,
alors rentre à la maison, je t'attends. »
Vous pouvez voir ici quelques photos.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Ces photos ont été disposées à plusieurs endroits.
Elles ont conduit la plupart des personnes à quitter la jungle.
C'était un très, très beau moment.
Nous avons décidé alors de travailler sur la société.
Nous avions réalisé la stratégie des mamans à Noël,
néanmoins, nous allions faire parler les autres personnes.
Comme vous le savez, il y a eu une Coupe du Monde cette année.
La Colombie a très bien joué. Ce fut un moment unificateur pour le pays.
Nous avons alors dit aux guérilleros :
« Venez, sortez de la jungle. Nous vous gardons une place. »
Ce message est passé à la télé et sur d'autres médias :
« Nous vous gardons une place. »
Le soldat dans la publicité dit :
« Je vous garde une place juste ici, dans cet hélicoptère,
afin que vous puissiez sortir et profiter de la Coupe du Monde. »
D'anciens joueurs de football, des présentateurs radio,
tout le monde gardait une place pour les combattants.
Depuis que nous avons démarré ces travaux il y a un peu plus de huit ans,
17 000 guérilleros se sont démobilisés.
Je n'essaie pas -- (Applaudissements)
Merci.
Je n'essaie pas de dire que c'est uniquement grâce à notre travail
mais je sais en revanche que notre travail
a sûrement aidé beaucoup d'entre eux à envisager la démobilisation
et à prendre leur décision finale.
Si c'est le cas, alors la publicité reste le meilleur moyen de changement
que nous avons à disposition.
Je ne prêche pas pour ma chapelle,
mais au nom de tous mes collègues présents ici,
travaillant dans la publicité,
et au nom de toute l'équipe qui a travaillé avec moi.
Si vous voulez changer le monde,
ou le rendre plus pacifique, appelez-nous.
Nous serons ravis de vous aider.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)